[inaudible]
joining me today as a sociologist,
a physician,
a professor at Yale University,
and author of the new book blueprint,
the evolutionary origins of a good society.
Nick Christakis,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me,
dude.
I am happy to have you here sir.
But I'm depressed that I have to start the show the way I sort of have to start
the show and I suspect,
you know how I have to start the show.
Yeah.
So do you want to set it up for me?
Well,
I mean we do just have to get this out of,
I know,
I know.
I mean,
I knew when the book was published.
I've been working in the book for nine years and I knew when it was published
that I would have to revisit those events from 2015 which,
you know,
we're just a challenging period of my life.
Um,
thankfully in the past.
I'm really glad to have it behind me.
Yeah.
But I recognize that.
So you tell whatever part of it you want to tell.
Okay.
So you are and were a professor at Yale?
Yes.
This is,
this is in I think the fall of 2015.
Yes,
it fall of 2015.
And your wife Erica,
who's also a professor,
uh,
childhood development.
She was an instructor but yes.
Yes.
So uh,
she basically wrote a piece that said it was a defensive free speech and it was
sort of worked around the Halloween costume idea that you know,
you should wear what you want but you can try to be respectful of people but you
know,
we shouldn't have some sort of top down version where people,
you know,
administrators or professors are telling students what were,
you offered her a bit of a defense on that and now I'll throw it in the clip.
Is that fair?
Fair.
Okay.
Let's throw it to the clip.
Don't need to bend down.
I'm not bending.
What's your name?
I don't want this.
I do not want you to take care.
I do not want,
I do not respect you.
I'm going to hear that.
I'm looking at this rec in your face like I'm disgusting.
Okay.
I am off and I'm sick watching them argue with you.
I believe we've been standing on stage literally for at least five to six hours
between you and Halloween,
which we last night to now,
we've been arguing with people who are not willing to be listened to for a long
time.
And all I see from you is arrogance and ego.
I am sick looking at you.
I am disgusted watching,
argue with you.
You are not listening.
You are disgusting.
I don't think you understand that.
And before I wasn't I before,
I was not angry per say,
I was disappointed.
Maybe I thought maybe there was room for it before an apology.
You've clearly told us that you did not plant.
Offer an apology for your words.
You left the meeting last night to go home and vent.
Tweak.
Do not interrupt me to tweet from your Twitter and then the filaments.
Twitter,
you showed no remorse.
You tried to let your wife leave that conversation without having answered for
herself.
That is disgusting.
That is sick.
And now I wasn't angry before.
I was not angry before,
but now I am actually angry sir.
I really do not interrupt me.
I was not angry.
And now I want your job to be taken from you.
I don't want you to have this job.
I am disgusted knowing that you work at Yale University where I will get my
degree.
Well,
I will look back and think I have to argue with you.
All right?
Don't Miss Sarah.
Don't do it.
Third,
to not do it.
This is not the day you do not want to play this game with meters out of thing.
You don't wanna play this game with me.
Okay?
Understand that.
Look me in my face first of all and understand that you are such a
disappointment to this university,
to your students,
to yourself.
Do the things that you do claim to agree with you are you want free dialogue.
You want free speech.
This is how it works.
Someone speaks,
you listen,
you're not cut them off.
You did not do these,
these condescending gestures.
You do not smirk.
You look them in the face and you wait.
You wait until it's your turn.
Okay?
So before we even dive into that,
the second we played the clip,
you let out a big exhale.
You just not was interested in this anymore or it's depressing to look back at.
Both are true.
It's,
you know,
it's,
um,
I was in the courtyard for two hours and 15 minutes from four to six,
15 about an hour of footage has been released of from five or six different
vantage points.
You showed one clip that's typically not the clip that's shown.
Um,
so many people put stuff online you can read,
you can piece together the whole hour between five and six.
For the first hour that I was out in the courtyard,
I listened quietly to the students.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of stuff that,
that young woman said that's just factually wrong.
Um,
she's alluding to an event that occurred the night before at the Afro Afro
American Cultural House at Yale where there was a huge event with hundreds of
students.
Um,
it had been announced at the beginning that,
that we would have to leave that event at the conclusion it was,
I can't remember the precise timing,
but I think it was scheduled from six to eight.
My wife had to teach a class from seven to nine,
so she deals in the evening.
So she told her students she'd be late and we'd stay from six to eight.
She did in fact speak to the crowd.
She,
um,
had to leave to teach an eye.
We had a student in the hospital actually that evening that I was responsible
for and that also was known.
So,
so when she said that we tried to leave,
that's not,
that's false.
Um,
you know,
I think that um,
many of the students were swept up in a kind of a mob fervor.
I think they behave badly.
Um,
they should have known better.
I think they were trying to assert power.
If I had a tool when I was that age that could get grownups into trouble.
Right.
Uh,
you know,
probably I would just get doing it nonstop,
and they have found a tool often are doing it.
Yes.
And so,
but so I think what distressed me is I think at some point in the background of
that footage that one of the administrators,
actually the author,
what happened is,
is a man by the name of Howard.
I had moved from north western university to Yale and had assumed a new position
there.
And he had written an email.
He had written a memo while at Northwestern,
uh,
admonishing students not to wear a offensive costumes.
And I should say for the record that many of the students that many of the
costumes that he or anyone else would find offensive,
I too would find offensive.
I wouldn't like these costumes.
I,
I'm well aware of the long history of racism in our society.
I am well aware of the ways in which,
uh,
there's trafficking and certain cultural tropes that put down other groups.
I reject.
I am of,
I've a very pro immigrant policy.
I believe system.
I,
I think that anyone can be an American.
I love the idea that we have open borders,
you know,
I mean I have all set of beliefs that are around openness and welcoming or
lefty.
Yeah.
I am quite lot.
I am a lefty.
I'm left of center plate.
I mean I have some conservative ideas,
some libertarian,
I think of myself as a classical liberal and I think of myself as very pragmatic
and policymaking.
So I like,
I like markets to address most allocation of goods,
but I also very concerned about market failures and then I want government
intervention.
Anyway,
so,
um,
uh,
so that,
anyway,
that man who was,
I then had moved to Yale and then he took out of mothballs this email that he
had sent at Northwestern five or 10 years earlier,
got a bunch of Yale administrators to sign it and then send it off.
And in it he had links to approved and non-approved costumes are very costumes
which were deemed to be offensive in his email.
There were links to lots of those ostensibly offensive costumes and the
students,
there had been a lot of conversation at the time.
The New York Times had a big piece like the previous month about the growing use
of Halloween costume advice at American colleges.
So it was in his,
like guys,
this was the third,
his email was the third email that had been sent out telling students,
giving them advice.
So in my wife's class,
many of the students in the class and other students in the college where we,
the subpart of Yale that we were responsible for had told her that they felt
this was very infantilizing and they didn't really need advice on what to wear.
And so my wife from a developmental perspective wrote a response to this email,
which itself had been,
was signed by 13 administrators.
It,
it didn't,
it was framed as guidance,
but it sort of had the color of law.
And um,
so she wrote a response saying,
and her intellectual point was not wear whatever you want.
Right.
Her intellectual point was,
do you students at Yale in your twenties early twenties late teens,
early twenties really need older adults to tell you what to wear,
provide you guidance.
You should think about that and decide whether you really,
and apparently many students did want such guidance.
And so then I was then thereafter,
then all hell broke loose.
And I was in the court courtyard and did the best I could.
Yeah.
What do you make of the reason we chose that cliff was because there is the
other more famous clip of,
of the growth,
really liberating with,
there were many,
many,
they were hired on you that,
that was the one that I think we should note here.
And I think that's the most of our little bubble.
I thought that one was interesting because the angle was a little different and
you could see some of the other kids and the,
and the,
you know,
the either tears or the look of horror,
all of these things when you actually didn't do anything.
Well that's another whole topic.
I think that,
um,
I mean many people have analyzed those events and honestly,
I don't,
I don't know if I have anything to add to those analyses.
I think that the thing that was very interesting to mean,
so,
so one of the ideas that I've been thinking about for a long time is this
tension between our individuality and our group of shyness.
And we have evolved to,
first of all,
it's a very interesting idea.
We've evolved to be individuals,
so we humans have unique identities.
So we have unique faces.
So you can look out at a sea of people and can tell who's who.
And not only do we have the ability to signal our uniqueness,
we use our faces for that,
but we have the cognitive apparatus to detect that uniqueness.
So you can have a lot of brainpower you haven't done,
you allocate to tell who's who.
So this ability to be individuals is crucial for our ability to function in
groups.
It's very paradoxical because you need the capacity to tell who's my offspring,
who's my friend?
Who do I reciprocate?
Kindness to,
who do I cooperate with?
Who's my enemy?
All of these things.
So all of these capacities of individuality are crucial to our collective
expression,
our ability to live together.
But equally we,
um,
we have this desire to surrender ourselves to the group,
to do something called two d individually,
to form a part of a collectivity to suppress our individual desires,
which also allows us to work together.
But the irony is when you'd get too much of that,
you get mobs,
you get panics,
you get,
you know,
uh,
all kinds of collective phenomena that are destructive rather than constructive.
So when I was in the crowd,
when I was in that mob,
I,
I knew what was happening,
I could tell.
So one of the things I started doing was as I started asking people,
what's your name?
And I was trying to connect to them person to person saying,
you know,
hi,
I'm Nicholas.
Who are you?
So you're a person and I'm a person.
You're not a part of this,
a mob.
You're a human being.
And I am a human being.
And in fact,
the,
the one thing that happened that that isn't as an intellectual idea,
that's part of this book that I've been working on for 10 years.
But that also I made in the heat of the moment is in the moment I said to the
students,
I said that I believe in our common humanity.
I believe that even though this person and this person is superficially
different than me,
nevertheless,
we can talk to each other.
We all have life experiences where human beings and ended.
And then if you,
if you don't believe that,
if you don't believe we have a common humanity,
which I see as a wonderful thing.
Yes,
yes.
Cause I'm an optimist.
I'm an optimist.
If you don't believe our common humanity,
why are you even trying to talk to me and the students geared to,
yeah,
they jeered it's on film.
They jeered and I honestly,
I think that's one of the most depressing things that's happened that I've ever
seen actually said the yields students in the 21st century would jeer at what I
regard to be a fundamental,
humane,
wonderful claim about human beings is that we have a common humanity.
So,
all right.
So I know you don't want to spend the whole time,
but I do.
But I think a lot of this does segue to your book for reasons that you just laid
out.
So those trying to do that.
Yeah,
I know you're a very clever,
you're tid bits.
You can,
I'll watch what,
I'm going to go back in there.
How did they get us there then?
Okay.
All right.
On his back.
Um,
but that look that you're talking about when,
when you say that,
like we have to be able to share a common humanity.
I've been there too.
I mean,
I face these mobs to do and what I find is there's an actual look they have in
their heads where the individual that you just spoke about is gone.
Um,
did you think there was anything,
so I guess there's really,
in that case,
for the people that are watching this,
that think that one day they are going to go against the mob,
is there any other advice you would have for them on how to,
how to do it?
Because that doesn't always work.
I mean,
saying I've done that where I've said,
I'm standing right in front of you.
I'm listening to you.
My name's Dave and it doesn't work that
I think that,
um,
I,
I don't know.
You know,
there's that,
there's that scene in Lord of the rings where Aragorn rushes the gates,
you know,
um,
and have more door.
And I of course love those movies.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't know if I would have,
I don't think,
I don't know if I would be capable of such bravery,
but,
um,
intellectually I definitely am.
That is to say I'm not easily cowed.
Um,
and I,
I have spent my life training myself to think as clearly as I can to look at
evidence to collect evidence.
I'm an if scientist,
I'm an empiricist.
So,
um,
so in the,
in the case of a mob,
I don't think I would yield to a mob intellectually.
Now,
physically,
you know,
if they're,
if they're throwing bricks at you as a different thing,
but I think
you too often that threat is always there.
Even if they're not holding a weapon that threads,
right.
It's a dangerous situation.
I would agree.
But mass,
you know,
[inaudible] are always dangerous.
But my point is that I think that if you,
if you can keep your calm,
you can think clearly about what you're saying.
Also,
if you've thought about these ideas before in the cool of the day,
so it's not the heat of the moment said,
look,
I really thought about these ideas.
This is not just a sudden heat of passion.
Like I've,
I've thought about this topic or this point,
whatever it is.
It doesn't have to be a political point.
It can be scientific point or something.
Then when you're pressed,
you know,
you can say,
I'm listening to you.
Here's what I think.
Okay.
What do you think?
I think you can,
you can,
I won't say you can win the battle of ideas,
but you can at least fight it.
Well.
Yeah.
What was the administration's response after this older,
well,
I think the administration faced a difficult challenge in deciding what to do.
Many people have commented on what they did or didn't do.
I'm not sure I want to go into it.
Um,
it took them quite awhile to come to,
to release any kind of public statement in support of us.
Um,
so,
and you know,
many members of the administration,
junior members were actually involved in,
so in the crowd that day,
they were four,
four administrators actually,
uh,
who,
um,
you know,
who's others have since identified.
But,
um,
you know,
I think,
I don't think it was Yale at its best and um,
and I don't in the students were not at their best and I was not at my best.
I did my best,
but you know,
I think I could've done even better.
So as someone that then has lived through it,
where did this go wrong on college campuses because for the past couple of
years,
every time I see one of these stories I think either,
well,
I used to think,
oh this,
this is the end of it now people will really get it.
Like I remember you're the one with you from the other video clip that we didn't
show that people had seen.
It was like,
this is so patently absurd.
Maybe this will finally be the wake up call.
I've now come to believe that the wake up call,
these can come at anytime soon,
sadly.
Um,
but what,
when do you think as well,
I think this is a complicated topic.
I see.
You know,
this is not,
it was not my area of expertise.
I am a natural and social scientist.
I run a lab with computer scientists and molecular biologists and sociologists
and evolutionary biologists,
and we work around the world who do all kinds of stuff.
So I was,
I have always been committed to liberal principles including to free speech
when,
when I was at Harvard,
before I moved to Yale in 2013,
uh,
my wife and I came to the defense of minority students who were being,
um,
having their right or speech rights squelched on campus.
So I'm committed to these ideas,
but it wasn't the most central part of my life.
And I'm not an expert like John Height or,
or Greg Lukey off look Kiana far,
however,
so,
so I see conflicting evidence.
I agree with you that there are a lot of these salient cases which,
which they weren't before.
And Jonathan feels that they're still rising and they have their own theories.
Jonathan and Greg about why I see other evidence that looks at surveys of
college students and finds that they are no more or less likely to want to
suppress the speech of others than adults and older adults.
It's very tempting to silence people who don't agree with,
right?
I mean,
everyone wants to do that,
but I don't,
I want to talk to them and persuade them like it would be,
it would be,
it's very tempting to like,
you know,
shut the anti-vaxxer is up,
prevent them from speaking.
But that doesn't win,
right?
That that's not a victory.
What we need to do is persuade them.
Why do you believe,
think this?
So,
so if you compare college students to adults,
some evidence suggests they're not more sanctimonious.
Some evidence suggests there are some polls,
uh,
if you look a disadvantage there clearly rising,
but they're still small.
So,
so the critics say there's a rising level of [inaudible],
which I deplore let me just,
can I go on a degression?
Yeah.
Yes.
So I have no,
let me be very clear because there's a lot of sloppy thinking about this.
Nobody has a right to speak on a college campus.
So I'm not claiming that anyone has the right.
But once a group on campus invites you to speak,
you cannot yield to the mob Verdis invitation.
It totally destroys the university.
It's,
it's the antithesis of what a university should be like.
So you can protest that person,
but you cannot have dissertations.
That's just ridiculous.
So,
so they're,
so those have been rising,
but so the critics say,
look,
this invitation had been rising,
but the defendant saying yes,
but millions of Tok state place and nobody objects.
So it's a tiny minority.
So to answer your question,
I don't,
I don't think we're beyond the hump,
but I'm not the expert to tell you.
How bad is it?
Does it say something about the state of liberalism or in a way that,
that this was sort of the end conclusion of liberalism?
I hate to say it,
that it would get sort of usurped by progressivism or whatever the new
collectivist idea was.
In other words,
liberals are tolerant,
liberals generally are live and let live.
So it was sort of fertile ground for people with bad ideas to Russian and kind
of take over where perhaps conservatives are a little harder to get in at
they derivatives.
Yeah.
But conservatives have their own political failings.
Right.
But I have no doubt.
Yeah,
they'll move in lock step.
So you can get them to like,
you know,
you two to mark to get,
to get to organize an inquisition.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's not like,
right.
We can conserve.
I'm Larry,
I'm not comparing either one.
I'm just saying that there is a weakness of liberalism,
which is very sad for me to say.
The openness is exactly what invites,
yeah.
So this is the radicalism within.
So I mean I think this is,
I mean I think,
you know,
the open society and its,
and its enemies.
Um,
you know,
I think there is a sense in which you can use the,
the tools to destroy the foundation.
Um,
but I also think,
and this is one of the arguments that I made and I actually believe politically,
which is that these very core commitments to freedom of assembly,
freedom of expression,
which the students were using right now.
Then we're also engaging in harassment,
which is a different topic.
And because I was an actor in those events,
I was,
I didn't feel at liberty to help the students see the difference between freedom
of expression and harassment.
Right.
Yeah.
Somehow I don't think they would've been like,
oh,
let's sit down and listen to him as you
explains why,
you know,
so you can,
so the classic example is the,
you know,
is that,
you can,
you can march through the streets of Skokie,
Illinois,
but you can't stop in front of my house.
Right.
Because,
you know,
that is a threat,
uh,
the political expression and a public places not so,
so,
uh,
so the students,
so the,
so,
uh,
um,
I lost my train of thought.
Where was I going?
Uh,
well,
basically the idea that the liberalism and uh,
yeah,
so,
so the,
so these are chord,
that sort of non-corrupt judiciary sort impartial separation of powers,
freedom of assembly,
freedom of speech.
I regard these as like foundational principles of our democracy,
which are essential liberal principles.
We wrote principles.
Yes,
yes.
Liberal Bristles,
which the students in some ways we're using,
right.
Um,
except to call for people to be fired for expressing their ideas in a collared
campus is using these principles,
but to a liberal ends.
And this is what you're asking,
I think,
which is what you're saying is can these tools be used to like degrade the,
and the answer is yes,
there is a kind of threat from within,
but I still wouldn't abandon the principles and I don't want to abandon the
peanut goes either.
Okay.
There we go.